a federal court in Maryland ruled on
Thursday that parents don't have the
right to reading now from daily Wire by
the way a federal court in Maryland
ruled Thursday that parents don't have
the right to opt their children out of a
curriculum that includes books about
radical gender Theory Biden appointed
judge Deborah L bourman said that
parents quote asserted due process right
to direct their children's upbringing by
opting out of a public school curriculum
that conflicts with their religious
views is not a fundamental right so just
to say that again
the the doe process right to direct
their children's upbringing by opting
out of a public school curriculum that
conflicts with their religious views is
not a fundamental right so in other
words according to this judge you
despite what you may think do not have a
fundamental right to uh decide how on
your children's upbringing and to um
take them out of uh programs that
conflict with your own personal values
religious views and how you want to
bring your kids you don't have that
right you do not have that right you
don't have that right over over your
child you don't have that right um over
your
family according to this judge last year
Montgomery County Public Schools uh
introduced 22 new books into Elementary
age classrooms that featured lgbtq
characters and radical gender theory
topics and then stopped parents from
opting their children out of gender and
sexuality instruction in
March uh the move sparked outrage from
Many religious parents who along with
Becket law filed a lawsuit challenging
the district's decision in May concerned
parents requested a preliminary
injunction that would allow them to opt
their children out of the lgbtq
curriculum when school begins next week
the the district's lgbtq curriculum is
intended to be taught to prek through
8th grade students and includes
references to sex change procedures drag
queens interex identity gay pride
parades and preferred pronouns according
to National Review one of the books also
says that doctors simply guess a baby
sex when it's born be at senior counsel
Eric Baxter posted on Thursday quote
today the district court decided parents
have no right to notice when extreme
ideology is pushed on their Elementary
age children during Story Hour with the
new school year beginning the case is on
the FasTrack to the fourth Circuit Court
of Appeals and the parents planned
appeal decision so you notice that as
always
the uh trajectory of these things that
I'm always pointing out but it's very
important that that we do notice this
but how does it always begin right the
left does something horrific and then we
point out that they're doing this
horrific thing and then they origin
initially they deny it and they say
we're not doing that that's
crazy and then eventually very quickly
and sometimes again I mean this this
this is a process that can play out over
these days this proc it used to take
decades for this process to play out now
it can play out in like 10 minutes um so
initially we say you're doing something
horrible don't do that and they say
we're not doing that that's a conspiracy
theory and then and then quickly after
that they'll say okay yeah we're doing
it but it's good and
then immediately they follow that with
okay yes we're doing it it's good and
it's
mandatory you have to
participate so rapidly it goes from
we're not doing that it's a conspiracy
theory to yeah we're doing it and it is
mandatory sit your kids down they have
to be here for it that's exactly what's
happening here it wasn't all that long
ago that the left would say I mean think
back to the the the fight in Florida
over the um the parental rights bill
that was named by propagandist that
don't say gay Bill even though it had
nothing to do with with that at all but
you know initially their response to
that is because that that was a bill is
a bill
legislation that forbids you know sexual
instruction instruction on on sexuality
gender identity for kids in prek through
third
grade as I said all along with this bill
the only problem with this bill is that
it stops in third grade
um and initially they said well this is
no one is doing
that no one's trying to talk to prek
kids about sex yeah you're
crazy and now in Maryland they're saying
yeah we're going to talk to your prek
student about about uh you're talk to
your prek child you're four-year-old
about these topics and you don't have
the right to stop
us that's what they're
saying and when they say what's the the
other side of that
coin when they say you don't have the
right as a parent to opt
out of sexual instruction for a
four-year-old the other side of that
coin is you don't have the right to opt
out because we have the right to talk to
your kids about whatever we want to talk
to them about well if you want some good
positive news in the the culture War
since roie Wade was overturned the left
has lost their mind they've made
abortion their official Sacrament the
pro-life efforts which are now more
important than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
Pro lifers didn't go away they have
increased in number as one of the
largest prif organizations in the world
no one is in a better position than 40
Days for life to end abortion in each
state in a post row America 40 Days for
life is changing hearts and Minds in the
most blue pro-abortion States they've
had a record number of locations since
um row was overturned and they grew in
both volunteers and locations with about
a million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by giving a
tax deductible gift of any amount at 40
days forlife.com that's 40 days
forlife.com and these parents in
Maryland all they're
saying y all they're saying is uh
is is is look you want to talk about
this stuff in school go ahead and do it
just don't just let us pull our kids out
okay they're they're being much more
moderate than I am than I would
be okay my my view is they don't talk to
this about any kids you freaks don't
don't have this conversation with any
kids you should be banned from talking
about school the parents are just saying
okay we're not even challenging you
talking about it we just want to pull
our own kids out that's
it and that's not good enough remember
the trans activist in the in the last
story said re well they're reasonable
criticism well we would we would
certainly be okay with reasonable
criticisms well you think if there was
if there was any kind of position or
criticism on the other side that they
would be willing to admit is at least
reasonable it would be something like
this you know it's it's this kind of
like compromised
position yeah you could talk about all
this disgusting stuff with kids just you
know but if I'm a parent I don't want my
kid to be a part of it just let me pull
them
out if they were willing to agree that
anything is reasonable then you would
think that they would say okay fine
that's reasonable I don't agree you know
but uh but I you know I think that the
public school should groom all the kids
but yeah okay it's reasonable if you
want to pull your kids up but they're
not willing to accept that even that is
reasonable because like I just said you
go along with everything they do and say
all the time in every case and you you
you are 100% obedient or you are a
genocidal transphobic bigoted Maniac
killer like those are the two options
you bow before them you offer your
children up to them as sacrifices on
their
altar
or your transfer bigot uh and you should
be dead two
options those are two options that they
that they
leave which is why all the alleged
radicalization that they uh pretend to
care about on the right if it is
happening guess whose fault it is it's
it's your
fault because you've left you know if
for for people for conservatives you've
only left two
options you've said we got to go along
with your entire
agenda or we're transphobic bigot
extremists and so a lot of us are saying
okay well I guess I'm a transphobic
bigot extremist
then and then there are people who say
well if I'm already that no matter what
then well
okay here's here's the crazy thing when
you label full everything
[Music]
extremism then you end up getting a lot
more actual
extremism how many of these
parents are now going to be uh
radicalized by this there going be a
radicalizing moment for a lot of these
parents who didn't start with any kind
of radical position all they wanted to
do was opt their kids out now they're
being told they don't have the right to
that's going to radicalize a lot of them
and it should
frankly radicalize them in favor of be
of the truth being radically in favor of
the truth if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wallow Twitter page
hope to see you there godp speed